Yeah yeah yeah
[music]
Today's
th me me Well of
Sharostia with my city
We're progressing.  I'm
always impatient about it,
yeah, that's all there is to it, Jack, if you
like it, it's deleted
Check it out
Ore no Stars sweet
Love Brothers Kokuzo Stationery Lurking in the Shiba Inu O God, I gave it to the sword, and
now I want to avoid it As the alliance ordered, there
were six virgins, ah, ah
At this point, I'm going to stay at home with a temperature of 7.
[Music]
Fighting Akita's specialty is good.  We are defeated by our
nemesis hero and the invasion is stagnating.
Afterwards, a
proposal from the development department about a new monster Guard
I think that's what I
expect.
But there's nothing to be afraid of if
you're just a believer in the power of the Pro-Kaishin No
matter how scary it is, it's
good to have someone who is timely.
It's been an
ani Shokaku Roy-san, who is everything in you?
[Music]
2 minutes
ni [
Music]
toranoana
[Music]
ni
nican you
do no
change
goo
aname
me
Music]
Goo
Kimisuke Agastia
Roll the evil spirits up to this point Tokueishun
black
tease
As long as there is justice in this way, Aku also
exists The key to
confronting justice and evil A
medley that fights in secret
[Music]
This  Today, we will start the presentation of the new type of Phantom
First, we will explain the use of the new type of Phantom throughout the country.
Please take a look at the proposal you have.
Car It
looks like it's a lot smaller than last time, but there's a
problem.
Anyway, if people watch the game this time, the fate of the nemesis new blader will be
decided.  I'm
surprised at how much I've grown,
but one day I'll be able to wear it with my patience bag.
This time, we went back to limiting the Phantom, and
focused on an extremely simple construction.We deliberately
abolished complicated mechanisms and functions, and
expressed aggressiveness with an extremely ferocious appearance in order to intimidate the blader and break the fibers.
Please
take a look, what's wrong with Ishii?
Kigurumi-chan, this made me feel like Star-chan,
so that's
it.  It's a
good day for Anas.
Omiho Megistus, the owner of the brain and the omnipotent ruler,
Trismegistus is called the Great Trismegistus
because he works three times as hard as a human.  It's
too disadvantageous for its fighting strength, but since it's
started, there's only a few battles.Contrary to its
appearance, it has strong power and endurance.  dare
There is no comparison graph with other monsters
dare
Next time
will definitely be the moon as per the material I'm concerned c Based on Blade's previous
monster data, it has better performance
I'm not happy  It's
too easy and too simplistic.
Related l letter and eat
me It
looks like that's all for this time Not yet Is it going to change to a mode mode?
In the ground monster, it's very bad
if none ah ah ah
teaching Radar attack
the name
Teaching the attack from the inside
car
[music]
ban
Yeah, it's interesting
whether
it's a law or not.  I'm not going through the pain of
using it, so I'm going to use it, so I'm going to use it.  Mr.
Kuroi really likes monsters, do
n't you think?  I did
n't receive it in the old days, so
it's bad that I let it all go. I just
gave up on the
black seed.  In fact, the
two of you are probably
not sleeping much because you've been working too
hard these past few days.
Reports have also come up from the department,
raging blade Odoi Shock First
protect your body.  It's a
big loss to lose someone with excellent psychology because of failures and mistakes.  The most
important thing is to grow steadily in your work I
have high hopes for the next project.
Hmmm
Ah, but
what should I
do with the examination braider?  That's a good feeling,
isn't it
?
At first glance it looks like an ordinary office b
But this is a
camouflaged building owned by a front company of the secret society Agastya.The
headquarters to be demolished is hidden deep underground.  Let's take a
break when we're done
[music]
tan
How's it going? We've just
finished adjusting
[laughter]
Transformation braider
Osuga and who will tear you apart with their own claws.  It's
because I was born
After all, this child is
close.
I'm early, and I'm an Earl
Glaider, so don't
rush, Wolf Bait.  I'll
send you an image of your body, a battle situation, with
Denki Konryo.
[music]
Oh,
I'm the one who's done with the water
.  Hey, I
woke up Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, it's
okay,
it's okay, wait a minute.
When is almost completed, your
Excellency Hey, he hasn't
changed either.
tree and me
ame
yes we did it eh eh we've
become puppets we've entered the path let's be
relieved in a way I
think we're still stubborn
some prime ministers might get viciously stabbed  There's
no difference in performance, so there
may be major bugs, but that
doesn't mean you can't push a patch to fix it later.  It's
not like I'm going to goo I like it I'm
just crying I'm tired You can go up today Thank you for your hard work
Ah, that
regular customer It's a
job that you can't tell people
I was also leading ko
ko What is a
job that can't be told to anyone?
]
Prosecutor Hanamaki
seems to reply to the enemy player transformation blader built into the medical examination bracelet.
Even rugger,
what a hell of a kid Henshin
blader, but when I was 22, I
had no experience with women
[music] Do
n't be fooled Don't underestimate the monster's power
car
Power was a shame  But the buster blade
button market was exchanged It's
still a tricky opponent
Luna Blader It's okay I think my ability is about this much
ni
[music]
rar is different
par
def
Health checkup department radar server female prosecutor 22 years old is a woman  I didn't
have immunity Hey, what are
you doing? Seriously, you're
just a silly saver of mine.
Haaaaaaaa
anacarme
[music]
C 4 is bralony
After all, it should
n't be
uploaded
at the last minute, isn't it?  I
received special data from Mr.